police and accused kidnapper and
attempted murder in Nye County remains
on the run the family says it's frantic
as it says he took his minor son with
him Victoria Saha has been piecing
together this story she has the latest
from Nye County in this case
we are in front of Ryan Sanders's house
The Man Who police say needs to be
captured after committing violent crimes
police believe he is still in the
Pahrump area but the biggest worry now
is that there's danger that could come
to his son who he took with him while
Law Enforcement wants you to be on the
lookout for 37-year-old Ryan Sanders
worry now shifts towards 13-year-old
Ryan Sanders Jr so as of right now I
don't know where my grandson is where
his dad took him to if he's alive what
Ryan's maternal grandmother Deborah
Hubbard is in North Carolina she says
Sanders has full custody of his son my
biggest fear right now is that his dad
is being pushed to the edge because he
knows he's going to go to prison and I
my biggest fear is that he's going to
kill them both Sanders and Richard
Duncan are accused of kidnapping and
trying to kill an elderly woman in
Pahrump on November 21st the victim was
asleep in her home when she woke up to
her house being burglarized the Nye
County Sheriff's Office reports Sanders
brutally beat her then forced her to get
into her car where he drove to a nearby
hospital to pick up Duncan the two men
then allegedly drove to a dirt lot where
they assaulted her again leaving her
unconscious Duncan was later arrested
social media posts show Sanders was
trying to sell all his belongings
earlier this month when I went to his
home on Monday there was no answer
belonging scattered indicating there was
a rush to leave the crime scene and
Sanders's residence is nearly a
three-minute drive from the victim's
home but for Sanders's son's family his
safety is their number one concern I
don't care if somebody blows Ryan's head
off I don't care I don't care what
happens to him my only concern and my
fear is my grandson is going to end up
dead the Nye County Sheriff's Office
says they have no reason to believe that
Sanders's son is in danger but that's
not a guarantee given the crimes that
he's accused of committing they have
also alerted everyone in the area to be
on the lookout for him reporting in
Pahrump tonight Victoria Saha 8 News Now